bonjour bienvenue pour le set suite sur
tv fil 78 nous allons faire le point sur
l'actualité locale au cours de la
prochaine heure comme chaque soir en
direct du lundi au jeudi et de 18 à 19
heures avec nos invités je recevrai tout
à l'heure notamment la présidente
d'espoir à tchernobyl association qui
accueille entre autres à des enfants
malades d'ukraine pour des soins et du
repos invité également au cours de cette
édition le directeur du centre de
formation à des compagnons du devoir des
pôles porte est ouverte du 22 au 24 mars
et puis déjà sur ce plateau gens nous le
plat bonsoir à vous tous merci de nous
avoir rejoints vous avez été reconduit
au début du mois dans vos fonctions de
président du comité départemental
olympique le dos vous allez nous
expliquer vos priorités on en parle dans
quelques instants auparavant voici et
les titres les sujets que nous allons
développer aussi au cours de cette
édition les conséquences de la neige qui
est tombée en abondance vous n'avez pas
pu la rater un tapis blanc a recouvert
les trottoirs et les rues de
l'agglomération à la galère forcément
pour certains a le plaisir pour les
autres c'est presque historique et cela
pourrait faire jurisprudence la corde
compétitivité était signé ce mercredi
matin par des syndicats de renault les
usines seront préservés dont celle de
flins est les détails les explications
avec l'un des syndicalistes signataires
6e biennale de poésie jusqu'au 31 mars
ce samedi les poètes sont descendus dans
la rue à la rencontre des passants ils
auront lu des textes d'auteurs
contemporains comme ici au centre
commercial 17 mar à elancourt et puis
toujours à elancourt la commanderie des
templiers à dévoiler ses secrets
l'occasion d'une visite découverte un
retour sur l'histoire de ce site qui
mêle tradition et modernité en
accueillant des expositions
contemporaines et pour la culture ne
retrouverons aussi ce soir aurélia de
bissy monsois aurélia il sera forcément
question de poésie oui comme vous disiez
tout à l'heure c'est actuellement donc
la 6e biennale de la poésie à saint
quentin en yvelines et nous recevrons
donc à cette occasion jacques fournier
le directeur de la maison de la poésie à
guyancourt qui viendra donc nous parler
des différents évènements qui ont lieu
sur les sept communes donc de la
communauté d'agglomération la page
culture au début de la seconde partie de
cette édition dans une vingtaine de
minutes mais on commence par la neige et
cette pagaille également dans le
département il y encore 48 heures
difficiles à venir ce sont les mots du
premier ministre ce matin à propos des
intempéries qui touchent une partie de
la france neige verglas ont entraîné et
entraîne toujours à de fortes
perturbations jusqu'à 2500 véhicules
bloqués sur l'autoroute a1
soixante mille foyers privés
d'électricité également dans les
yvelines la situation est aussi
compliqué mais dans une moindre mesure
la vigilance est tout de même de mise
l'alertent orange est d'ailleurs
toujours en vigueur le point sur le
secteur de saint quentin en yvelines de
versailles avec ce sujet de julie rocha
soirée c'est de patrick jacques de
dixmude
ça patine encore ce mercredi sur la
route presque habitué les automobilistes
vigilant adoptent une conduite prudente
pas commis arrière c'était difficile je
n'avais pas conduis et
mais ce matin ça va ça patine pas trop
dans la non non ça va cette annonce a
été là ça se passe pas trop mal à 7h30
c'était un peu dur mais bon vu que à
montigny ça pas été déneigées depuis
hier 19 heures et jusqu'à ce mardi 4
heures 30 la casse qui a assuré trois
épandage de bouillie de sel et trois
sorties de l'âme pour déneiger les
patrouilles ont depuis signalé aucun
problème de voirie elles sont
d'astreinte depuis le début de l'hiver
au départ on avait donc les 1200 tonnes
de sel de départ voilà là aujourd'hui
doit me rester à peu près 180 tonnes
en moyenne je pense une 35 35 fois au
moins m sur un réseau de 200 kilomètres
à chaque fois dans chaque sortie du côté
de la sncf les prévisions annoncées ont
été tenues avec des difficultés
ponctuelles sur notre secteur notamment
des dysfonctionnements de mécanismes de
portes et du givre formés sur les
caténaires d rame stationnée cette nuit
à trappes qui ont entraîné des retards
et suppressions ça se passe pas tout
simplement
normalement je travaille à la défense
mais toute façon ça fait qu'il ya plus
de trains donc peut-être qu'aujourd'hui
on a je vais essayer de voir ce dont
j'ai la chance d'avoir des bureaux aussi
sur saint quentin en yvelines donc voilà
je vous redis ici trop quand je peux pas
y aller la société ski bus a suspendu
son trafic toute la matinée certains
usagers ont été prévenus par sms
d'autres ont attendu en vain leur bus la
solution de repli le taxi on a beaucoup
de monde on n'arrive pas à fournir des
gens arrêtent pas d'appeler on est peu
nombreux à travailler évidemment avec
les conditions donc voyez beaucoup de
monde là ça s'est calmé mais depuis ce
matin ça n'arrêtait pas
si la neige perturbe les transports
elles facilitent les descentes en luge
et fait le bonheur des enfants
reste à remonter la pente et voilà
pourquoi ne pas utiliser la luge pour
aller travailler en tout cas ces
automobilistes bloqués dans la
circulation vous les avez vu et entendu
dans les médias tout au long de la
soirée ir mais avez vous rencontré de
telles difficultés dans le département
des yvelines
comment se sont passées les dernières
heures pour vous voici quelques
témoignages recueillis aujourd'hui ça
s'est plutôt bien passé parce que
j'avais prévu j'avais anticipé j'ai
travaillé chez moi hier et aujourd'hui
j'étends crochet je suis juste à côté
donc j'ai eu aucune difficulté pour la
neige un petit peu à hergé pas était en
cours mon père m'a dit non c'est pas la
peine que ça y est tous c'est une vraie
patinoire
j'ai de la chance de ne pas travailler
je regardais la neige derrière mais mais
taro et mon chat sans français revenir
n'est pas de bien mouillé pas de bus les
rer tous en retard on n'a pas pu aller
travailler la sncf n'a même pas été
capable de faire des justificatifs
on était une centaine de personnes dans
la gare à attendre pendant trois heures
sans résultat sans nouvelles sans
explication c'est une catastrophe parce
que la voix que je prend d'habitude elle
est fermée pour travaux et la voix de
correspondance elle est tombée en rade
avec la neige
donc j'ai dû prendre la voie de la
correspondante de la correspondance j'ai
mis deux heures et demie burns balade
justement parce qu'on ne veut plus
travailler mais je profite pour être
avec mon fils